welcome back we're finally using the
laplace transform to do something useful
in the first part of this problem we
just had this fairly straightforward
differential equation and i know it's a
little bit frustrating right now because
like this is such an easy one to solve
using the characteristic equation
why are we doing laplace transforms well
i just want to show you that they can
solve even these problems but later on
they're going to be classes of problems
that frankly
are our traditional methods aren't as
good as the laplace transform but anyway
how did we solve this we just took the
laplace transform of both sides of this
equation we got all this hairy mess
we use the property of the derivatives
of functions when you take the laplace
transform and we ended up after doing a
lot of algebra essentially we got this
we got the laplace transform of y is
equal to this thing we just took the
laplace transform of both sides and
manipulated algebraically so now our
task in this video is to figure out what
y's laplace transform is this thing
and essentially what we're trying to do
is we're trying to take the inverse
laplace transform of both sides of this
equation so
another way to say it if we we could say
that y we take the inverse laplace
transform of both sides we could say
that y
is equal to the
inverse laplace transform
of this thing 2s plus 13 over
s squared plus 5 s plus 6.
now we'll eventually actually learn the
formal definition of the inverse laplace
transform how do you go from the s
domain to the t domain or how do you go
from the frequency domain to the time
domain we're not going to worry that
about that right now what we're going to
do is we're trying to we're going to get
this into a form that we recognize and
say oh i know those functions though
that's the laplace transform of whatever
and whatever and then we will know what
y is so let's try to do that
so what we're going to use is something
that you probably haven't used since
algebra 2 which is i think where when
it's taught in you know 8th 9th or 10th
grade depending and you finally see it
now in differential equations that it
actually has some use
let me write we're gonna use partial
fraction expansion
and i'll do a little primer on that if
in case you don't remember it so anyway
let's just factor the bottom part right
here and you'll see where i'm going with
this
so if i factor the bottom i get s
plus 2
times s plus 3.
and what we want to do is we want to
rewrite
this
this fraction
as the sum of two
i guess you could all call it partial
fractions i think that's why it's called
partial fraction expenses so we want to
write this as the sum of
a over s plus two
plus b
over s plus three
and if we can do this
then and you you might already bells
might already be bringing in your in
your head we could we know
we know the laplace we know that these
things that look like this are the
laplace transform of functions that
we've already solved for and and i'll do
a little review on that in a second
but anyway how do we figure out a and b
well if we were to actually add a and b
if we were to let's do a little side
right here so if we said
that
a
so if we were to give them a common
denominator
which is
this s plus two
times s plus three then what would a
become we'd have to multiply a times s
plus three right so we'd get a
s plus three a
right
this as i've written it right now is the
same thing as a over s plus 2. you could
you could you could cancel out an s plus
3 on the top and the bottom
and now we're going to add the b to it
so plus i'll do that in a different
color
plus
well if we have this as a denominator we
could multiply the numerator and
denominator by s plus 2
right to get b
times
s plus 2b
and that's going to equal this thing
that's going to equal
right all i did is i added these two
fractions nothing fancier than there
that was
algebra 2. actually i think i should do
an actual video on that as well but
that's going to equal this thing
2s
plus 13
all of that over s plus 2
times s plus 3.
notice in all differential equations the
hairiest part always the algebra
so now what we do is we match up we say
well well let's add the s terms here and
we could just say that the numerators
have to equal each other because the
denominators are equal so we have a plus
bs
a
plus b
s
plus three a
plus two b
is equal to
two s
plus b
so the coefficient on s on the right
hand side is two the coefficient on the
left-hand side is a plus b so we know
that a plus b is equal to two
a plus b is equal to two
and then on the right-hand side
we see three a plus two b must be equal
to what else oh this is a 13. did i say
b this is a 13.
that's a 13. it looks just like a b
right that was 2s plus 13.
anyway so on the right hand side i get
was it 3
3 a
plus 2 b
is equal to 13.
now we have two equations with two
unknowns and what do we get i know this
is very tiresome but it'll be satisfying
at the end because you'll actually solve
something with a laplace transform let's
multiply the top equation by 2
let's just say minus 2. so we get minus
2a
minus 2b
equals minus 4.
and then we get so add the two equations
you get a
is equal to these cancel out
a is equal to 9 great if a is equal to 9
what is b equal to
b is equal to
9 plus what is equal to 2 or 2 minus 9
is minus 7
and we have done some serious
simplification because now we can
rewrite this whole expression
as the laplace transform of y
laplace transform of y is equal to a
over s plus two is equal to
nine
over s plus two
minus seven
over s plus three
or another way another way of writing it
we could write it as equal to nine times
one over s plus two
minus seven times one over s plus three
why did i take the trouble to do this
well hopefully you'll recognize this was
actually the second laplace transform we
figured out this was the second laplace
transform we figured out what was that
i'll write it down here just so you
remember it was the laplace transform
of e
to the a t
was equal to
1 over
s minus a that was the second laplace
transform we figured out
so this is interesting so if we were to
take this is the laplace transform of
what so if we were to take the inverse
laplace transform actually let me just
stay
consistent so that means that this is
the laplace transform
of y
is equal to nine times the laplace
transform of what
if we just do pattern matching if this
is s minus a then a is minus two
so nine times the laplace transform
of e to the minus 2 t
does that make sense
take this put it in this which we
figured out and you get 1 over s plus 2.
and let me clear clean this up a little
bit because i'm going to need that real
estate
let me
i'll write this i'll leave that there
because we'll still use that
and then we have minus 7
times
this is the laplace transform of what
this is the laplace transform
of e to the minus three t
e to the minus three t
right this is just pattern matching
you're like wow you know this
this if you if you saw this you would go
to your laplace transform table if you
didn't remember it you would see this
you're like wow that looks a lot like
that it's just i just have to figure out
what a is i have s plus 3 i have s minus
a so in this case a is equal to minus 3.
if a is equal to minus 3 this is the
laplace transform of e to the minus 3t
so now we can take the inverse laplace
transform actually before we do that we
know that this because the laplace
transform is a linear operator and
actually now i can delete this down here
we know that the laplace transform is a
linear operator
so we can write this and you normally
wouldn't go through all of these steps i
just really want to make you understand
that we're what we're doing
so we could say that this is the same
thing as the laplace transform
of nine
e to the minus two t
minus seven
e to the minus three t
now we have something interesting
laplace transform of y is equal to the
laplace transform of this
well if that's the case then y
must be equal to
9
e to the minus 2t minus 7 e to the minus
3t
and i never proved to you but the
laplace transform is actually one to one
transformation that if a function's
laplace transform if i take a function
against laplace transform and then if i
were to take the inverse laplace
transform the only function whose
laplace transform that is is that
original function it's not like two
different functions can have the same
laplace transform anyway a couple of
things to think about here notice
we had that thing that kind of looked
like a characteristic equation popped up
here and there and we still have to
solve a system of of two equations with
two unknowns those are both things that
we had to do when we when we solved an
initial value problem when we used just
just traditional the characteristic
equation but here it happened all at
once and frankly it was a little bit
hairier because we had to do all this
partial fraction expansion but it's
pretty neat the laplace transform got us
something useful in the next video i'll
actually do a non-homogeneous equation
and show you that laplace transform
applies equally well there so it's kind
of a more consistent theory of solving
differential equations instead of kind
of guessing solutions and solving for
coefficients and all of that
see you in the next video